surface restorer at and surf racer was
born in 1942 in Edinburgh in Scotland UK
he was awarded a PhD in 1966 from
Edinburgh University and he has also
moved around quite a bit during his
career but he is now a board of trustees
professor of chemistry at north
Northwestern University in Evanston just
outside Chicago in Illinois USA and just
want to say one more thing and I will
welcome surf racer up to the stage that
surfacer is part of the so-called Fraser
clan in in Scotland in north of Scotland
if I understand correctly and the Fraser
clan is well known for being extremely
stubborn and but well very trustworthy
people I think both of these
characteristics are very good for
science but there is a third
characteristic for it Fraser planned it
they are very very fierce in battle and
so and I think maybe that is also
something good for science actually
sometimes so by that sir Fraser please
welcome up to the stage
well thank you Olaf honorable hosts
fellow laureates respected guests
it's an enormous honor for me to be
standing here and sharing this platform
today with John Pierce of Irish and Ben
Ferengi the coal areas that have been
recognized by the Noble Foundation and
they're all Swedish Academy of Sciences
I want to take you on a story that will
reflect in some ways the citation the
design of synthesis of molecular
machines based on the mechanical bond
now jean-pierre has already introduced
you to Kathy named Sandra taxanes
I like to use this word that was coined
by first back in 1953 the mechanical
bond to describe a situation where
within a molecule you have a physical
bond between either two rings or between
a dumbbell component in a ring this is
not a chemical bond it's a physical bond
and as such I think it's a very much
revolutionary change in chemistry we
often refer to them as mechanically
interlocked molecules and I just treat
up this definition by Wikipedia to
underline the fact that even Wikipedia
appreciate that these are not super
molecules they are molecules and you see
how they are derived from Latin as is
the two ring situation
I want to segue into immediately because
we've had a wild marvelous introduction
from job Pierre into a structure that we
when I say we David I'm a Bellino who's
in the audience made in the mid 90s when
I was at this marvelous University of
Birmingham and here you see a yellow
component and a green component have the
same
chemical constitution as do in a pair
the blue and the red one the black one
is this like the expanded version
because it has to accommodate a yellow
and a green ring here of the blue and
the red here is a framework
representation which shows the
interactions that I'm going to be
talking about primarily during my
lecture between PI electron rich units
this dioxin app Saleem unit for example
and these by pyridinium units the only
collective nation that you see here is
that that you can find in DNA and in
proteins and in fact these pi PI
interactions in this direction here over
here and in this direction here are
aided and abetted in a huge amount but I
hydrogen bonds and also to a lesser
extent by CH PI interactions which you
find in proteins the Olympian in
molecule I should say came to the world
without too much effort on my part Isis
a David in the audience which was the
synthetic chemists and the crystal
structures you're looking at are the
courtesy of David Williams there's 12
professor of structural chemistry the
Pierre called London you'll see that we
went on and made a branched seven
catenin and there is the crystal
structure of that particular molecule
now at one time I was hoping that the
Olympic movement would rally around and
support my research but the opposite was
true they don't like to see any use of
their Olympic signed and some of you may
know from the response during the London
Olympic Games to the butcher's Prytania
rings of sausages and their windows that
were colored like this okay so
I want to pay a tribute to ed Wasserman
because it is debatable maybe I know
that whether this was the first
Cassadine that was made back in 1960 but
you can see as a result of an acyl M
so-called condensation and using some
deuterium lately it could be argued if
you read this paper carefully that this
was maybe the first kind of name to be
made but look in a very very small yield
that's this maybe is an overstatement of
the yield in this reaction jean-pierre
already mentioned the very important
publication in 1964 by Godfrey chill
from freiburg university this was 22
step synthesis of which you see in a
telescope down weighed the last four
steps of the synthesis and this involved
the use of classical chemical bonds
covalent bonds to bring the pieces
together
and then at the end of the day to cleave
them and one of my Bibles has been this
book cata names for taxis and knots
written by Godfrey chill and translated
published in English in 1971 and now of
course I play homage to the remarkable
breakthrough it was a game-changer
this French article in tetrahedron
letters which I did struggle to read a
little bit where are you jump here but
we got the message from all these
beautiful representations and here I
have perhaps more detail in them you've
already heard the story from Jean Pierre
so it was in 1989 after about a decade
of developing molecular recognition
around donors and acceptors that we
carried out the reaction in which we
started off with this died cation and a
crown ether over here that I will call a
template and these do - don't speak to
each other there's no molecular
recognition but as soon as
this carbon nitrogen bond is formed you
have a by pyridinium unit and this wants
to make its way inside this kind ether
so that you can get donor acceptor
interactions have melted by hydrogen
bonds and then finally another nitrogen
carbon bond formed and a kudu ketamine
is the result and the amazing thing for
us in 1989 was that this arrived with a
70% yield now the crystal structure
again was led by David Williams and I
know that Peter galaxy's from the
audience he helped to orient it that
molecule I remember in a pub in
Sheffield in a particular way that
leaves it I think attractive so now we
rotary taxanes been using the same type
of thought process here's our template
now we don't have a ring anymore we have
a dumbbell and again no recognition but
very easily in a one-step reaction you
can take these chemicals here and see
the Nitro and prepare presumably in the
first step the same as the last time
with the gasoline and then see these non
covalent bonds coming into place in the
taxon environment and again getting
closure and this time of course not was
the same high yield this with the
Cassadine because this is more flexible
template but still a very respectable
32% yield now the importance of this
discovery and this takes us to 1991 now
is that this was the first example in
our lab of what we called the molecular
shuttle this is a pure attack seen where
the ring can dart back and forth even
see about 2,000 times a second at room
temperature in the acetone the next
challenge was to take away the
degeneracy in that system and make it
non degenerate and otherwise turn it
into a switch sorry replaced one of the
hydrocodone rings by this
biphenyl unit and by the Spencer Dean
unit the story here firming is such a
beautiful place we were not allowed to
carry out the chemistry using benzidine
in Birmingham and Richard Bissell had to
go to University of Miami where the
restrictions on using pens again weren't
so high and made this compound in Miami
University under the guidance of an elk
- and now you can see we have a
situation where the ring spends most of
its time on this unit here the benzidine
unit until it is protonated and because
the ring carries four positive charges
the ring moves away from the protonated
benzene unit to form another species
where it is in circulate the by phenol
unit and all of this can be controlled
obviously by pH now I'm moving on to the
first device that was made at UCLA in
collaboration with Jim Heath and what I
want to show you here is in a movie how
the synthesis is carried out so this is
now a tetra tie full valine unit and
this is a dioxin a saline unit here you
see the temptation of the blue ring
around that unit this is a hydrophilic
stopper and that's a hydrophobic one and
by again redox chemistry we can put
positive charge onto that
TTFN unit and have the ring move to the
dioxin ethylene unit equipped with this
type of amphiphilic relaxing now we
could fabricate a cross bar device in
which by hard lithography you could
prepare a chip with say four wires on it
this goes into a so called line your
trough and in the language of this mono
layer molecules is squeezed together
until it's at a right
level of pressure to when the chip is
brought out by the so called
langmuir-blodgett technique the mono
layer is spread onto the surface of
these four wires and then more hard
lithography is required and all of this
was done in Jim heats lab at UCLA in
subsequently Caltech to give us a
so-called 4x4 cross bar device I go fast
forward over a decade we had a wonderful
collaboration with Jim and this is now a
400 x 400 crossbar device with wires
around about 60 nanometers wide and this
gave us the basis for a 160 kilobits
molecular random access memory Jim was
quite hard on the switches that he had
the fresh hold had to be at least 1.5 in
this diagram here so this meant that
three-quarters of them for one reason
another were condemned but at least 1/4
Rubin than that allowed him to punch out
using the ASCII code California
Institute of Technology on a device
where we have white blood cells here
here is the device here are white blood
cells and so we're looking at a device
that is in its cross-section smaller
than the cross-section of a white blood
cell and this is less was 2007 roughly
where the semiconductor industry is
expected to be by 2020 one thing was not
to our liking about these switches and
that is they don't last they might go at
best through a hundred switching moving
motions and then the system just
degrades so I want to give you some very
up-to-date results and so this is a
paper that's just been accepted for
publication and in fact has appeared now
in which we've used this by stable
catenin with the same principle of
playing off PTF against the dioxin
apslund unit placed inside a metal
organic framework by a technique
that has been featured and developed by
my two colleagues Joe Harper no more
fire are called solvent assisted ligand
corporation so you just plug these
switchable Catanese into the pores of
what is called Nu 1000 this particular
morph and you can see here this is a
film where you can see switching just by
looking at the absorption around about
800 of the TTFN unit and that switching
is taking place I can't tell you how
robust it is yet the other development
of our work at UCLA was in collaboration
with Jeff think where we put essentially
Rotax scenes on the surface of Mesa
porous silica nanoparticles and showed
that we could use these and I have a
movie here to show you the incorporation
of drugs under a concentration gradient
and then using the rings on their attack
scenes to close up onto the surface hold
the drugs inside and then let them in
principle be admitted into the
environment to a cell here's the cell
coming and the amp the capsule is inside
and when you give it a signal by any
means possible then the drugs will spill
out and of course this is not going to
be good news for this cell okay so I'm
going to make a fast transition now to
molecular machines and they are going to
be based on their so called flashing
energy ratchet mechanism and so this is
where we need to have a situation where
we can get unidirectional motion to
begin with in a situation and I'll use
cartoons to begin with where we use the
cyclo fin you're already familiar with
and we want to be able to bring it on to
this dumbbell such that it comes over
the neutral end and after having done
that because of the recognition between
the nap saline and the ring system to
eject it by the right hand side
it over the charged end and this is
achieved by juggling around of energy
barriers so here is the lower energy
barrier comes over the neutral one and
then by changing the oxidation state a
reduction state of the Ring and taking
it to a base radical cation we reduced
the positive charge and it comes off the
right-hand side so this is a way by
which you can get one of the necessary
things to be able to build a molecular
machine that is getting unidirectional
motion okay so again we are inspired by
nature I just want to point out that
bacteria rhodopsin uses the same
principle to pump protons across from
outside to inside the cell here is a
chemical constitution of the dumbbell
that you've been looking at and you've
seen the cycle of thing before
and again this principle can be used to
make what we've called a molecular pump
so this is the prototype that allows us
to take the ring on from the right-hand
side and leave it from the left-hand
side anyway we didn't have enough as it
were driving force in this particular
system and we were able to change that
situation for the better on the back of
a discovery made at the end of 2009
published in 2010 and Stewart Cantrell's
journal and he's in the audience and
this amazing discovery that Atris
radical tri cation can be a very stable
species allowed us to be able to play
off reducing against oxidizing
conditions and so one can contemplate
now a situation where we turn the
dumbbell through 180 degrees the charge
system on the dumbbell is on the left
hand side now in the neutral one on the
right hand side and we're going through
a sequence of reductions a relaxation
oxidation relaxation and we could show
that we can direct the ring from left to
right this former for a temptation can
be illustrated by the making of the
homo catenin in the series of the
so-called blue box and this was carried
out by Jonathan Barnes who's in the
audience in a remarkable 41 percent
yield based on the interaction that was
such a surprise it was so surprising
that it's been described by one of my
postdocs as an intellectually disturbing
invention as it were and this monitored
radical can be further oxidized to a
totally oxidized octa cation and there's
the crystal structure of that one hi
Ramon time 10 minutes thank you
we can effect radical temptations
also in the Rotax in the era area by
simply using a photosensitizer and a
sacrificial electron donor and the
result is the formation again of this
Ches radical try cationic complex and
when you see these AI groups at the end
at least every chemist knows that you
can carry out in principle that
so-called quick reaction with an
appropriate alkyne and we were able to
do this or wholly no a professor in
China very efficiently the point about
this system is that when you bring it
out of an inner atmosphere this
chemistry has to be done in say nitrogen
or argon then columbic repulsion will
take place and the ring will be pushed
away from the formal by period in iam
dark a time so here is the design of the
molecular pump
we're what you see going on here with
this movie is the juggling amout of
transition states and energy wells to
allow this rain to come on when it is in
a reduced state and then to be sent to
the left-hand side over a barrier we
call this a speed bump sometime and when
we get it over there it is such that it
cannot make its way back and this is the
again cartoon version and we have a long
collecting chain here this is where we
want to collect these rings and
demonstrate that we are doing chemistry
as you'll see away from equilibrium and
otherwise we're moving away from
molecular switches to molecular motors
another movie here that shows the rain
coming on from the left while it's being
reduced and then after being oxidized
going over the speed bump and when the
second one comes on the first one wants
to come back but it can't because of the
speed bump so there's an enormous amount
of delicate stereochemistry involved
here and a huge amount of synthesis the
process that we're looking at again is
one of consecutive reduction oxidation a
little bit of thermal energy needed to
push this ring over the speed bump into
the collecting zone and further
reduction and oxidation at thermal
process to bring the second half ring on
so it's interesting that pumping one
followed by two rings is possible and in
the context of doing this we are more
and more taking a system away from
equilibrium and what was very
interesting was that we could carry out
the first redox cycle here in a 90%
yield the second one a little lower
seventy-seven percent yield
sorry 85 percent yield overall 77% yield
for the production of this to continue
and what I want to point out is the
energy barrier that has to be crossed
to put the second ring on is within
experimental error of that for the first
string and so what we're seeking to do
now is to use the same type of approach
the radical chemistry with a redox
system that involves reduction forming
the very strong complex and then
oxidation giving coulombic force that
pushes it to the right and you'll notice
as this happens I'm increasing the level
of the energy here and so we're going up
in energy we're doing work and this is
what the biological waters do as well
yeah that's the fourth one so each cycle
traps one ring in a high energy state
some of the energy input is trapped and
we've gone from working with molecular
switches to molecular screens because
work has been done time fine okay now
why would we be interested in going down
this road because everybody's looking
for applications and let me give you a
taste of what might be an application
so-called entropically dominated poly
Rotax ames and so now we're putting the
pumping part of the molecule at each end
of a long polymer chain and using a
light powered system and even an
electrically powered one we can show
we're making progress here that we can
do work progressively and repetitively
from each end of these polymer chains
and I take a movie here to show you
what's going on in solution we have the
redox chemistry reduction followed by
oxidation forcing the rings on over this
speed bump in two different parts to the
ends of the chain here so that we
accumulate a lot of rings in an
environment where they are both
entropically and enthalpically unhappy
so what's the consequence of this well
before I come to that I just want to
summarize the principle that we're
developing here and that is to use a
very stable
interaction of a host guests nature and
then after the reduction process to get
this to happen an oxidation process to
switch on columbic forces at a very big
level so that we could have highly
unstable species and this forces the
units to come apart so we have a
modulation here involving kinetics of
Association and kinetics of
disassociation we're doing chemistry
away from equilibrium and the point I
want to make here is that if you've been
an undergraduate in chemistry or a
graduate student in chemistry in the
last 50 60 70 years it's usually been
all about equilibrium processes in the
class we've got to move now into the
direction of studying systems that work
away from equilibrium because this is
how the motors in our bodies work so
what are some of these big questions in
this context they are what are the
consequences of dissipation on materials
properties
well the hint that these could be very
useful because in Japan professor Ito
and Cato have using cyclodextrins and
polymers like petrol PE ethylene glycol
polyethylene glycol have been able to
show that you can make these so-called
site ranked materials and these show
properties of being scratch resistant
but we would like to be able to do this
in a more widely defined arena involving
organic solvents and organic chem type
polymers so we want to be able to design
systems that operate repetitively and
progressively away from equilibrium
along the lines that I've just been
describing ok so just to summarize this
has been a journey that's taken at least
25 years although I will just step back
for a little while at the very end to
point out that to get to 1991 was
already a decade
for a lot of shall we say difficult
experiments that seemed to take a long
time a lot of situations where things
didn't work out the way we expected
eventually by the turn of that decade
when we went to Birmingham we were able
to make the generate molecular shuttles
and to put into them radically enhanced
redox witches by 2010 we then could
introduce unidirectional translation as
a result of having these asymmetrical
dumbbells first of all we use donor
acceptor interactions but find that the
discovery of the radical chemistry made
it much more feasible to make linear
motors and we had to optimize Palumbi
barriers after having optimized stearic
barriers there the chemistry that was
done here in making these energetically
demanding transport systems ultimately
led to the production of these
artificial molecular pumps and in this
context there are these early players
and I should recognize the very
important contribution of theoretical
chemist computational chemist Bill gourd
art a Caltech because we do everything
with a lot of computational work deenis
to me and who's been really our guide
through all of this physicists from the
university of maine and then other
people who some of them in the audience
Jonathan Barnes Christian pazatto Paul
McGonagall and Julian Chen who've really
pushed forward our work on molecular
machines the leading molecular
machinists I would of course recognize
right away Michael laureate bad for
anger but I just want to put up with
some trepidation of course the same that
was expressed by jean-pierre survives
other main players in this field so
Vincenzo both Anna
um Alberta Ferretti who's in the
audience my ex student David Lee
Dean assuming again Joseph my co
colorado and Prag steve Lubin canada
eddie civic in australia they and you
Miguel Garcia gotta be at UCLA graphic
liner the Wrightsville Institute and
were flood in the audience even
prohibited the audience and I know that
also Nicolas you're supporting us in the
audience so I think the field is moving
forward at great numbers and the
recognition by their overall Foundation
and the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences will I think give it a great
impetus um can I just take one minute
okay can we go back to Nobel laureate
Alfred Werner because some of the
introduction that I didn't put in
because I thought I might not have time
goes back to Alfred Werner and then a
man called Jewish at who was associated
with Imperial chemical industries where
I spent three very productive years
between 1978 and 1981 before we go there
here is just a statement for the young
people in the audience in a review by
chat that I think it's worthy of some
mention scientific discovery is not yet
predictable note that if you have an
excited road to follow do not be put off
by those who say there is nothing at the
end of it they do not know persevere and
enjoy the excitement of exploring the
unknown and I think you're free
laureates in chemistry have all
experienced some of the sentiments
written there in the audience's heard
cohoon from the University of Reading
who when I first knew him was at IC i--
and here is the crystallographer that i
paid homage to earlier and this student
Alex Lowen and it was the entry into a
field of second sphere coordination
involving transition metals and
bipyridine ligands that led insects
excessive steps to organic systems that
were very like the transition metal
based ones and this happened in my lab
during the 1980s finally just to
recognize the importance of the human
and financial resource situation first
of all this was my postdoctoral mentor
in Canada came Jones this was the
professor of the school of carbohydrate
chemistry at Edinburgh Sir Edmund Hirst
under whom I studied he was a student of
Walter Norman harbors 1937 Nobel
laureate in chemistry who was a student
of Ottawa 1910 Nobel laureate in
chemistry and they go back through
calculate and wait for this one in color
you recognize him
so I've got a good link to Sweden here
and back of course to Waller who are
challenged the vital force in his time I
just put up a few of the postdocs and
graduate students that have played a big
part in my research over almost five
decades now and also some of my
collaborators at Northwestern Berkeley
who's about to host a panacea nano who's
sitting over there
and Roger patent of course it's not all
done without some brass as we call it in
Britain so I got lot of support
ultimately from this University of
Birmingham it was amazing when I went
there in 1990 and also the period from
Imperial chemical industries well
supported by both universities in the
United States UCLA and northwestern and
the funding agencies there but last but
not least in recent times the king of
dual City for Science and Technology in
Riyadh in Saudi Arabia and I will just
close there and allow time permits about
400 names to come and go in red and blue
that have contributed to my research I
wouldn't be standing here if it wasn't
for the contributions by this amazing
group of people you know it's a enormous
privilege to work no sorry to practice
one's hobby every day along with young
people roughly between the ages of 22
and 32 and their names are going up
there I've been so privileged
they're very privileged to be here thank
you
[Applause]
thank you so much for this fantastic
inspiring and animated talking and also
very visionary and it's really nice to
see some some results that are really
hot off the press I always want to give
results the press and also the link to
bear Sirius was fantastic thank you so
much